[Music]
in poor baby news pop baby submitted by
take you with me take you with me please
broke-ass baby a healthy dog was
euthanized because the owner wanted it
buried with her what the foe
who the [ __ ] does this owner think they
are [ __ ] Empress well how old was the
dog though they don't mention her I just
want to feel okay yeah me same like it's
a two year old dog and it's like I give
this like a 15 year old ah it's not
right but I don't feel better
ya know they do mention it was young and
healthy but it was young if it was young
you didn't even have that much time with
their lady it just lasts puberty nobody
down would have took the doll y'all get
help you know so that's why a lot of
people are upset because they didn't
even try so the the animal shelter said
that they could have easily found a home
for the stock zoos friendly was young it
was healthy but this freakin lady hey
like I said she's an empress that [ __ ]
want to die with all the servants
Egyptian sure not dead how did they how
does she know if the dog gets euthanized
that's exactly what I said to my mom so
she's wait what okay what she said your
mom think she's the Empress - no she
said she goes she goes when I die she
does I want you to take my ashes and
spread it out in the ocean and I go well
you're [ __ ] dead how would you know
if I did it or not I'm gonna put it in
the toilet what's the damn difference
but she was like that's right it's true
you know they didn't have to put it down
maybe by law it's in her will or
something exactly dog that's about to
die anywhere but don't you want to be
one with your spirit on the kill list
look alright make the dogs with the bet
with those back legs that don't work and
they have the dragon oh you don't want
your you don't want your cat spirits to
go with you live and be happy well who's
gonna protect you with after well
they'll die eventually
and then they'll meet you yeah and it'll
go like this for me because I'm already
dead and like things go by really fast
there and there's a cat train yeah
there's a kitty train I really wish we
had carnations true I think it is I
think it is the Buddhist that's like
that's the Buddhist the way of thinking
that we all return back to
energy source and then we reincarnate as
something other life but if you look at
everything in the universe it all like
it all reincarnates it all like a see a
tree dies and then it becomes season and
neutrals like some sort of equilibrium
that's like a black hole like sucks in a
whole universe and spits out a new one
like it's fun if you're like hey science
hey there's a lot of science that we
carbonation exists I've ever seen
someone with a really hairy back yes
they used to because my friend has
shoulder pads that was furry man was a
puppy before wooly mammoth oh that's
cool but he'd be nice though like oh yes
so there's the animal shelter was saying
that they were trying to talk to the
executor of the woman's estate execute I
know right damn I'm picturing this guy
now yeah executor the lawyer
executor I don't know I just don't want
her to be the executor executor that's
type now I'm doubting myself no no
you're fine this huh no your that's true
it's I'm just saying I don't want him to
be the executor because you'd like he's
also indirectly executed it's a double
entendre because it's like execute is
like death but also to execute the
orders that's what it was meaning it but
then I think I started doubting myself
like are they spelled differently no no
they do pick and they not read there's
not picture you have to have a breakdown
girl let's talk about the story
ethics Anthony is [ __ ] wild on that
side no breakdown shut it anyway this
person they were trying to convince him
to not take the dog and obviously that
was unsuccessful because they want to
die with the dolls they'll take the dogs
so means it's not against the law dog
into bow Holly I found out that they're
the people that are executing this they
are not against the law like it's still
perfectly legal oh it's usually so this
isn't something that's new when owners
want their pets to go with them but
usually the pet is bold and like can't
be rehomed and like it's like two
grandpas yeah so then they're saying
that that's when it usually happens I
think if they want to do that they have
to do it themselves have to hold the dog
in the lap yeah yeah and then put their
mouth on top of it the only way they get
themselves making someone else do the
deed that's not fair Oh herb died hey
you kill them if you want that person
now you got to do put all the dogs you
have in ancient times when Emperor died
all of the servants and everybody and
his concubines were in the tomb two
alive and then they locked the door
didn't I oh my god like always no it
happened too many cultures people say
that it's not getting better in the
world use culture all kinds of different
called unity I was a servant of the king
I would do everything to keep them alive
doing everything and what sucks is these
people are why he's probably airing the
people he likes to like we get up Bernie
yeah he's like I want you to come with
me yeah cuz in the afterlife baby wants
his whole crew the last [ __ ] month of
his life I'm cursing him out okay he's
like dead and you're weak end up burning
maybe laughs in the afterlife that's why
I'm thinking like I don't know that that
might be the same concept where people
die die like oh my I want their spirit
to go with me oh god [ __ ] that I need to
pet them in the afterlife
yeah I know what anything I'm like dogs
tell if they're super young they're not
gonna be that attached to you right I
feel like they can go to another home
and then behead perfectly fine I just
don't know how you know dogs are
resilient no if you give them food and
pet them so they are saying that state
laws bar internment of humans and pets
for in for profit profit for profit sir
cemeteries why can't I say that you got
it I like prop it I like it better two
countries we got English already is a
cemetery so
for-profits cemeteries but cemeteries on
private land at churches or nonprofits
graveyards are not covered by state laws
and so you could have a human pet burial
oh [ __ ]
I don't want my dad beat Barry with me I
do 100% I'm gonna ride him into Valhalla
[Laughter]
because he actually has a photo like it
my cape that forgive me was it that a
unicorn that your honors a hippo
Oh dogs are the best dog I just think
the fact that the clean up the poop
after is so annoying you've been in the
afterlife you can hire someone and you
never have to think about it that's true
but that costs money man but then you
don't have to think about it people
watching a boob is funny it is so
straight in it shakes yeah and then they
look back at you this is the arch it's
just so stupid looks so dumb
cats do it the same way right I've never
seen a cat poop but I just know that cat
pee smells be worst cat pee yeah it's
worse than cat poop just any kind of
smell ever
like happy is strong that's when it's a
a male that's unneutered hmm regular cat
pee is just like smells like normal
people yeah yeah well if that helps for
sure if you guys had the choice of dying
with all of your friends and pets
together at once would you do it yeah no
I wouldn't kill you I was like if we
were all like an apocalypse situation
I'd be like okay I'm down to drink the
kool-aid to be alive if Steve is dead
I'd rather just be dead at the same time
okay but now or you talking about in the
future because right now what Muriel
died I'm okay but if I'm talking about
in the future like I've been with her
for 40 years yeah she's been my whole
existence waiter told her straight up
she's not allowed to die before me yeah
same with the same with I have to bet
we're not a lot of time before each
other
that really I don't think we're like
that doors tell me if I'm gone you'd die
yep I mean when I'm resilient I don't
know if I would be like that I would be
[ __ ] heartbroken but I don't know if
I would want to die I wouldn't want you
to die attacked I needed your help still
okay what take is completely capable I
don't know if I would want Tigers
capable now dude we were in the colors
we heard the Carson attack see Japan but
you have to just reached out he grabbed
my hand i legit thought it was a
grown-ass man
it's disgusting a little bit climbs so
these hands are strong so this will just
be somebody he held my hand and I was
like the [ __ ] part has three hands this
was smiling at me like visit like that
why his hands so strong it feels like a
grown-ass man's hand dude damn
disgusting cute little face strong as
hands good I want to be immortal so I
don't want to die with you but if this
was like 300 and it was like we all got
to make a stand together then we're all
doing it you know that shield at all do
death is quick if it's like oh we're all
getting tortured together oh if we got
caught know if it was like it just quick
oh yeah then I'd be like yeah let's do
it but if it's like oh we're gonna take
you prisoner and torture you if you're
all getting tortured or don't want to
survive torture and survive with me so
you're gonna break if the Persians catch
you you're gonna be like I tell you [ __ ]
edit done like all right we're gonna
torture you like I tell you everything
No I'd be like I'm killing myself and or
whatever
yeah or berries yeah I'd have like
poison in my in my arsenal so I would
just poison myself
that's tight if there are berries but
yeah the only way to die is you have
seven days of the most excruciating
stomach pink pain and you have to throw
up and diarrhea ever would you take
those berries no I would just kill
myself okay
the easy way suffocate myself in a sink
or some [ __ ] okay
really hard that's too hard I take the
berries over suffocation oh really
I think suffocation over being burned
alive man that's tough I don't want to
drown testing my loyalty here someone
else suffocates yeah it's not that bad
yeah good blacked out before it's not
that bad it's not it's painless all
right I do that we're gonna try to
rescue you if you got if you got caught
cuz you're gonna you're gonna spill no
poison myself like the like the agent
icky any secret don't tell her anything
too late I know everything caught by the
Persians